okay going from Roger stone to another
indict II and actually a someone
convicted in association with their
association with Donald Trump that is
two weeks ago we heard from former Trump
lawyer Michael Cohen who is of course
heading to prison for three years at the
beginning of March we heard he wants to
testify and he is voluntarily going to
testify before the House Oversight
Committee okay great news looking
forward to it
definitely someone I would want to hear
from before he goes to prison if anybody
has the goods on Trump its Michael Cohen
last week we learned okay now Cohen is
no longer going to voluntarily testify
because of threats made by a Donald
Trump in Rudy Giuliani against members
of Cohen's family so unfortunately it
doesn't seem as though we're going to
hear from Cohen before he goes to prison
except that now the Senate Intelligence
Committee has subpoenaed Michael Cohen
for a mid-february appearance which will
likely get him in front of elected
officials before he goes to prison but
there are so many caveats here that we
have to talk about number one it will
almost definitely be behind closed doors
so who knows if and when we will find
out exactly what Michael Cohen says but
this also is not the only subpoena that
Cohen is likely to receive we heard from
House Oversight Committee Chairman
Elijah Cummings House Intelligence
Committee Chairman Adam shift ship
rather both are expecting testimony in
their committees from Michael Cohen
they may also subpoena him to appear
before he has to report to prison on I
think it's March 6th of this year so
more than likely at least the Senate
testimony we wouldn't know the details
of right away but the details would
probably make their way back to trump
meaning that if Cohen spills goods we
would hear it indirectly via Donald
Trump losing it on Twitter one idea
that's being floated is that the Senate
is controlled by Republicans Republicans
want to have more of an opportunity to
control the narrative around Michael
Cohen
so they want to get him in front of
their committee first and sort of get a
head start
period and the evidence to support that
would be okay well Richard Burr is a
Republican he's the guy who runs the
Senate committee and he's saying let's
do this obviously with Democratic
support burr has been a okay with easing
sanctions on Russian oligarch Oleg
Deripaska who's all wrapped up in this
scandal so it's possible that he and
some other Republicans have decided that
that they want to get control of Cohen's
testimony sooner than later but the
truth is as we talked about last week
Cohen is very unlikely to actually spill
new information about Russia related
stuff because that does relate to
ongoing investigations my prediction Pat
and you tell me if you agree or disagree
is that most of the testimony whether
it's behind closed doors or not is going
to be about mistress payments and sort
of tangentially related to stuff that we
already have some sense of yeah I don't
think we're gonna learn that much even
when these testimonies are held in
public we tend not to hear too many
revelations like when James Comey
testified before Congress or Andrew
McCabe or Rod Rosenstein I think this
will be more of the same what I want to
hear about more though is how Trump and
Giuliani threatened Michael Cohen
because that could be witness tampering
yeah and what so that actually is a
story that by by not developing over the
weekend
it sort of has made it more likely that
when Michael Cohen cited threats from
Donald Trump and Rudy Giuliani he was
referring to to public statements that
it doesn't actually appear as though
private threats have been made Trump
said that it's Michael Cohen's
father-in-law that should be looked into
and then subsequently when Rudy Giuliani
was asked whether it's appropriate or
not for a sitting president to do that
Giuliani sort of played coy and said
well if the guy has participated in
criminal activity then of course it's
appropriate for the president to suggest
that and in there is every indication
right now that when Michael Cohen cited
threats from Trump and Giuliani that
that's what he was referring to and I
know that much like you pat I was
thinking okay well is is this a
reference to that
or is it a reference to some private
threats that were made at least now no
particular reason to think that private
threats were made but a number of legal
experts say that just those public
statements from Trump and Giuliani would
in normal circumstances count as witness
tampering of course when it's the
president doing it and the president is
already under investigation for a whole
litany of other possible wrongdoing
unlikely that that particular instance
of witness tampering as insane as it is
for me to say this is going to rise to
the level of being one of the primary
targets of investigation against Donald
Trump send me your thoughts about this
I'm on instagram at David Pakman the
show is on Instagram at David Pakman
show very slowly building up the show's
Instagram account now over 5,000
followers I predict 10,000 not too long
from now we will take a break and after
this break we're gonna have something
interesting I'm gonna be speaking to
Benjamin studebaker who wrote an article
about the decline and fall of Elizabeth
Warren as he sees it and we are going to
try to hash out what are Elizabeth
Warren's
liabilities and what are her assets in
the context of the 2020 Democratic
primary my prediction is Benjamin and I
are not going to be completely on the
same page on this one that's coming up
right after this quick break I'm
thrilled to tell you that today's
program is sponsored in part by untuk it
I also have breaking news for other
gentlemen who if they are anything like
I used to be or maybe still are that
long bulky dress shirt doesn't look good
untucked okay I used to think it looked
casual it actually looked really really
sloppy because those shirts were never
meant to be worn that way and what
untuck it does is make shirts that are
specifically designed to be worn
untucked they're not too long they're
not too short it's the clean casual look
that you can even wear at the office
depending on where you work with more
than 50 fit combinations untuck it
shirts look good on tall short slim
athletic types of
all ages I've had a couple of great
untuck it shirts which I wear untucked
as designed and they look great go to
untuck it calm or visit one of untuck
it's fifty stores across the United
States and Canada they even are offering
free shipping and returns on all orders
in the United States and most
importantly this is like the most
important thing about all of this use
the promo code Pakman to get 20% off
your first purchase if you want the
perfect fitting shirt regardless of your
shape and size try the original untucked
shirt and remember use the promo code
Pakman PA KMA n for 20% off your first
purchase at untuck it calm